[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 21 avril voici
les titres
l'information a été révélée il ya
quelques jours 18 lancements de la fusée
ariane 6 vont être effectué dans le
cadre du projet clipper d'amazon un
contrat historique pour arianespace
filiale d'ariane groupe installé aux
mureaux antonin ferry directeur
commercial lanceur d'ariane groupe est
notre invité à trois jours du deuxième
tour de la présidentielle beaucoup
s'interrogent encore sur leur vote pour
ne pas s'abstenir un mort pas y en a
fait le choix de donner sa voix à sa
fille de 10 ans elle s'est rendue aux
urnes avec son père le 10 avril dernier
et puis vous le voyez cet espace a été
inaugurée hier pour sa réouverture
annuel le parc france miniature compte
une nouvelle aventure est en cours elle
est dédiée à koh lanta cette occasion
sur ce site d'elancourt clémence castel
qui ne figure emblématique de la célèbre
émission télévisée est venu pour cette
inauguration mais avant de développer
ces titres un énorme feu de forêt s'est
déclaré en début d'après midi dans la
commune de rochefort en yvelines d'après
les informations relayées sur twitter
par les pompiers des yvelines plusieurs
hectares seraient touchés cinquante
pompiers sont mobilisés sur place
l'incendié est stabilisé mais
l'intervention est toujours en cours
aucune habitation n'était touchée est le
maire de la commune sylvain lambert et
la sous-préfète de rambouillet florence
ghilbert sont sur place et des axes
routiers sont fermés aux environs de la
commune de rochefort en yvelines il
s'agit des axes départementaux
27les route départementale 27 988 et 132
on ne connaît pas encore la nature de
cet incendie
[Musique]
et j'accueille à présent mon invité dans
ce journal c'est antonin ferry bonsoir
bonsoir que vous êtes directeur
commercial lanceur chez ariane groupe on
va parler avec vous dans un instant de
ce contrat historique signé avec amazon
mais avant elle je vous propose de
regarder ce sujet de mélanie poquet
malgré la distance avec les sites de
lancement l'industrie spatiale est bien
implanté dans les yvelines avec la
présence de grands acteurs et de
laboratoires de recherche
[Musique]
elle n'entraîne pas des astronautes mais
l'estac à montigny-le-bretonneux à sa
filière spatiale l'école forme des
ingénieurs ce qu'ils pensent les
lanceurs les engins ou l'exploitation
des satellites
[Musique]
enfin phil hay ses positions vingt ans
qu'il attendait
novembre 2014 comme un accomplissement
pour les équipes de loger est ce qu
laboratoire de l'université versailles
saint quentin a participé à
l'élaboration de cet instrument sur
rosetta et l'eurobond fila est lové
excuse c'est aussi du vs cus a tu le nom
de cet élu du latmos placé en orbite en
janvier 2021 ou encore persévérance le
rover présent sur la planète mars
le rover persévérance est d'ailleurs
équipé d'une caméra wi entend un laser
un dispositif conçu dans les yvelines à
buc plus précisément derrière la
conception 3d plus
maître d'oeuvre d'ariane 5 ariane 6 le
groupe du même nom a son siège aux
mureaux il vient de décrocher un contrat
avec amazon pour 18 lancement de son
dernier fleuron sur trois ans des
lanceurs spatiaux réutilisables aux
loges en josas laboratoire de sioux
space services pense à la mise en orbite
de satellites créée en avril 2020 la
start-up emploie 35 collaborateurs
encore en phase de développement le
premier vol inaugural est prévu en 2025
l'espace est aussi une histoire de
passionnés ou n'en font pas leur métier
mais scrute souvent le ciel plusieurs
clubs d'astronomie sont présents dans le
département comme celui de vélizy
villacoublay où deux plaisirs le radio
club de saint quentin en yvelines a même
participé à la mission de l'ue vécu ça
donc une place prépondérante de l'espace
dans les yvelines je rappelle cantona
ferrain ferry est avec moi au plateau
directeur commercial lanceur ariane
groupe qui est installé aux mureaux
alors ça a été dit dans le reportage
arianespace et amazon ont signé début
avril à un accord 18 lancements d'ariane
6 sont prévues dans le cadre du projet
clipper d'amazon ni arianespace ni
amazon ont communiqué sur les montants
de ce contrat rassurez vous je vais pas
vous les demander en plateau mais on
parle d'un contrat historique c'est le
contrat le plus gros contrat jamais
signé pour arianespace absolument je le
confirme à écouter ses ténors une énorme
satisfaction et une énorme fierté parce
que ce contrat qui est le plus contrat
le plus important jamais signé de toute
l'histoire du lanceur ariane en fait
c'est un c'est un pari gagné c'est un
pari gagné c'est une victoire de
l'industrie européenne qui témoigne de
l'excellence technologique des européens
donc on en est évidemment extrêmement
fiers de vous parler d'industrie
européenne parce que on précise juste il
ya 83 lancement qui sont prévues en tout
dans ce projet clipper d'amazon est
finalement marianne c'est le seul acteur
non américain qui va intervenir sur sur
ce projet exactement exactement dont
nous sommes honorés de la confiance
qu'ils nous avaient témoigné était
témoigné qui je pense est le résultat de
la réputation de fiabilité car yann a
développé au fil des ans avec les
différents modèles actuellement ariane 5
avec un très beau lancement réussi à
noël dernier celui du télescope james
webb et demain ariane 6 le nouveau
fleuron européen et donc c'est un
contrat signé alors que mon oreillette
part c'est pas grave je vais là je vais
la mettre de côté c'est un contrat qui a
été signé on le rappelle par arianespace
filiale d'ariane groupe dont on parle de
deux choses différentes quelle est la
différence entre arianespace ariane
groupe alors vous avez deux groupes
industriels de groupes excusez moi
d'être différent ariane groupe qui est
un groupe de sept mille personnes
filiale d'airbus et de safrans installés
en allemagne en france et ici aux
mureaux vous l'avez rappelé les mureaux
ville de l'espace nous concevons et nous
fabriquons la fusée et nous avons une
filiale qui arianespace qui est chargée
d'opérer cette fusée et de la
commercialiser c'est donc la filiale
chargée de la commercialisation
on travaille évidemment la main dans la
main et c'est parce que nous avons
travaillé de manière intégrée
extrêmement efficace que nous avons
réussi à décrocher ce contrat mais juste
avant de vous demander les coulisses
comment c'est négocier comment a été
décroché ce contrat qu'est ce que le
projet kuyper si on peut l'expliquer
très concrètement à nos téléspectateurs
le projet clipper en fait c'est ce
projet porté par amazon d'une
constellation de satellites pour de
rendre accès internet accessible sur
l'ensemble de la planète donc c'est plus
de 3000 satellite qui vont être mis en
orbite basse dans les années à venir et
qui vont permettre d'avoir une
excellente connectivité internet sur
l'ensemble du globe donc l'idée c'est de
placer en orbite ses satellites ça va se
dérouler sur combien d'années ces
lancements à peu près 80 3 à 4 ans donc
et comme comme vous l'avez rappelé un
travail collaboratif entre plusieurs
lanceurs et nous sommes le seul lanceur
non américain à avoir récupéré une part
du contrat je précise juste que dans ce
projet est aussi un 38 lancement qu'ils
soient seront assurés par l'américain
eut là et 37 par blue origin qui a été
fondée par jeff bezos le patron d'amazon
a justement comment ça s'est nouée cet
accord quels sont les coulisses qu'est
ce qui a porté le choix d' amazon sur
ariane justement en fait un contrat
comme ceux ci c'est une aventure c'est
quelque chose qui dure pendant deux ans
qui a des hauts des bas des périodes
d'attentes beaucoup de suspense
également donc c'est quelque chose qui a
commencé fin 2019 avec des visites
secrètes un du client qui ne voulait pas
faire connaître son identité à l'époque
puisque le projet était sous scellés et
donc il est venu nous rendre visite ici
dans les yvelines aux mureaux la fin de
voir l'état d'avancement et l'état
d'avancement de la conception du nouveau
fusent de la nouvelle fusée ariane 6
cette visite s'est bien passé nous avons
on est amazon à coup vous également
assisté un lancement qui s'est
extrêmement bien déroulée et donc c'est
comme ça que ceux ci a été enclenchée
que la relation était enclenché
mais ensuite nous avons
comment ces discussions dans le contexte
dégradé du que vidal et bien qu'en mars
2020 l'ensemble de la planète été mises
sous confinement donc nous avons
réussi à entamer les discussions dans ce
contexte
et puis nous avons remis finalement au
cours de ces deux ans quatre offres
successives pour s'ajuster de plus en
plus aux besoins du client avec en
s'appuyant évidemment sur la
connaissance d'arianespace qui a
développé une connaissance intime des
besoins de ce client et en s'appuyant
également sur les équipes d'ingénieurs
d'ariane groupe est de leur longue
expérience en matière de développement
de lanceurs sur l'ensemble de nos
partenaires européens puisque ariane
c'est 600 entreprises petites et grandes
dans 13 pays européens et sur les
agences spatiales comme le cnes ou l'
agence spatiale européenne et pour
s'élance mais à paarl d'ariane 6 qui va
remplacer ariane 5 ces nouveaux lanceurs
qui quelles sont les évolutions à les
émulsions son majeur donc on a
extrêmement fiers de ce nouveau lanceur
ariane 6 qui présente
des particularités
techniques extrêmement innovante qui lui
ont permis d'aller décrocher ce contrat
donc déjà ça en sort plus compétitif
c'est également un lanceur qui est
capable de faire des choix qui est un
lanceur intelligent il est capable
d'aller positionner très précisément sur
son sur orbite une série de satellites
donc ce que l'on fait aujourd'hui avec
ariane 5 s'est envoyé un ou deux
satellites en orbite ariane 6 à un étage
supérieur
polyvalent doté d'un moteur
supplémentaire d'un moteur auxiliaire
qui lui permet d'aller positionner ses
grappes de satellites un peu partout au
bon endroit sur les orbites et donc
d'être parfaitement adapté pour déployer
les constellations mais tout comme
ariane 5 les principales étapes de
fabrication de ce lanceur avant ce fait
romero absolument donc les mureaux c'est
le site de conception et c'est également
le site de fabrication du premier étage
du lanceur ça ne change pas donc ça ne
change pas pour ceci des mureaux on
imagine aussi à un carnet de commandes
qui qui s'est rempli grâce à ce nouveau
contrat du coup quelles sont les
retombées ce qu'on parle de création
d'emplois d'emplois pérenniser plutôt
d'emplois pérennes sur sûr
sur ce sujet alors ce stade on parle
effectivement
d'une montée en cadence de ce lanceur
qui correspond exactement à ce qu'on
attendait donc on est en phase de
consolidation
et donc 7 en fait on va passer d'une
d'une cadence de production d'environ
4,5 pour ariane-5 à une cadence 10 à 11
pour ariane 6 c'est une progression
massive et l'ensemble du système
industriel avaient été dimensionnées en
anticipation pour pour cette cadence
donc on parle plutôt de
effectivement de de consolidation des
mesures actuellement en place avec une
place centrale on imagine pour le site
des mureaux un berceau de cette fusée
ariane qui a une histoire en plus
centenaire on va terminer juste sept ans
présent puisqu'on arrive déjà à la fin
sur le calendrier les premiers
lancements sont prévus pour quand du
coup alors lire sont les prochaines
étapes donc les prochaines étapes ça va
être d'abord de finir le développement
et de lancer le vol inaugural de cette
fusée ariane 6 puisque nous avons vendu
cette fusée alors qu'elle n'existe pas
encore c'est donc ça aussi l'exploit
commerciale et la confiance que nous
manifestent
donc là nous avons deux essais à ces
critiques que nous allons réaliser cette
année des essais à feu de l'étape
supérieure et un pour la première fois
un essai de la fusée sur son pas de tir
à kourou et si tout va bien cela nous
emmène un premier lancement en fin
d'année et à partir de là nous
enchaînons la montée en cadence
industrielle et nous commençons à
annoncer qu peur à partir de la fin de
l'année 2024 voici les prochaines étapes
et ou par les cours bien sûr le port
spatial européen qui suit est situé
pardon en guyane française merci antonin
ferry à d'être venu en plateau pour nous
parler de ce contrat historique signé
par ailleurs ariane espace avec amazon
et je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur commercial lanceur chez ariane
groupe merci d'avoir été avec merci à
notre invitation
[Musique]
et j moins 3 avant le deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle au lendemain
du débat entre emmanuel macron et marine
le pen la question de la participation
se pose toujours au lieu de s'abstenir
un habitant de maurepas a décidé de
donner son vote à sa fille de 10 ans
après plusieurs discussions et
réflexions diane a fait son choix et
s'est rendu aux urnes avec son père lors
du premier tour le reportage de mathilde
franco je me suis dit bas plutôt que de
m'abstenir parce que finalement ma voix
sert à rien est ce qu'il y aurait pas
une autre une autre solution et puis
j'ai considéré qu'il ya dix ans comme
elle s'intéresse déjà depuis plusieurs
années qu'elle pose des questions ça
pourrait être intéressant pour elle de
donner sa voix donc je vais proposer
qu'on regarde ensemble les différents
programmes des douze candidats et
candidates qu'on puisse
en parler si elle avait besoin répondre
à ces questions lui expliquer les deux
termes qui sont pas forcément évident
quand on a dix ans j'ai regardé des
vidéos de quelqu'un qui tannait des
informations et j'ai essayé de voir ce
qui serait mieux pour eux pour nous
c'est ce que je pense sur le niveau de
la jeunesse l'école parce que je voulais
dire que autant qu enfin on n'est pas
que des trucs pour les grands par
exemple j'ai regardé un petit peu sur ce
qui est sûr l'écologie genre
l'immigration parce que je veux pas
complètement être isolé des autres ça a
pris assez longtemps mais à chaque fois
j'essaie de mettre une note sur 10 de ce
que je trouvais bien ou pas ça m'a aidé
à me décider j'ai eu des 2 sur 10 ouais
t'es qui pour eux madame le pen parce
que je trouve que c était sympa qui pas
terrible chez moi je pense que c'est pas
ce qui m'intéresserait le plus et
c'était parce qu'il peut et galère
console en particulier l'important pour
moi c'est que ça soit
raisonnée peu importe le choix qu'elle
fera c'est que elle y est pensé que l ai
pensé aux arguments qu'elle ait pu poser
les questions si elle a besoin et que ça
soit pas un choix vu sur il a l'air plus
gentil ou ou elf pas les plus jolies et
en choix s'est porté sur qui alors sur
le candidat jean luc mélenchon parce que
je trouvais qu'ils les tuent voté
beaucoup pour l'égalité du côté jeunesse
on faisait des avantages et hier
mercredi c'était donc le débat de
l'entre-deux-tours traditionnel débat de
la présidentielle emmanuel macron et
marine le pen ont échangé sur leurs
programmes et leurs différences durant
près de trois heures où ils friedrich y
fait le débrief de ce débat avec le
député des yvelines bruno millet
[Musique]
dans quelques jours nous irons donc aux
urnes pour désigner le président de la
république bruno mylène est notre invité
bonjour est député de la 9e
circonscription élus du modem soutien de
la république est en marche et donc du
président candidat emmanuel macron hier
se tenait donc ce débat du second tour
de l'élection nous avions prévu
également ce jeudi de vous faire
débattre face au rassemblement national
sur ce plateau mais sont responsables
dans le département nous a signifié je
vais reprendre ses termes que le
déchaînement des médias en général
envers leur candidate les oblige à
annuler débat et interviews dont acte et
nous vous recevons seul aujourd'hui pour
débuter j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment
sur les échanges de mercredi soir
comment avez vous jugé la prestation de
votre candidat alors j'ai commencé
peut-être sur la prestation de des deux
candidats en fait le débat était plus
intéressant qu'en 2017 parce que plus
poser finalement plus calme on a pu
entendre vraiment le fond des projets de
et de l'autre et ça c'était important
parce que du coup ça a donné un
éclairage beaucoup plus significatif que
ce qu'on avait pu avoir en 2017 alors on
s'est aperçu d'un côté qu'il y avait un
projet chiffré il y avait des
expériences du présent la république et
de l'autre côté un projet plus porté sur
les slogans on l'a vu ça a commencé très
mal pour marine le pen avec le pouvoir
d'achat où finalement il n'a pas été
compliqué de démonter locher que son
pouvoir d'achat basée simplement pas que
simplement mais en partie sur la bge et
eva ne tenait pas et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on dénonce déjà depuis des mois
qui malheureusement a pas été souvent
repris dans les médias en général
la tva la baisse de la tva d'abord c'est
quelque chose de terriblement injuste
puisque ça profite en réalité aux plus
riches puisque ce soit ou qui consomment
le plus donc c'est nous étions bien
difficile aux trousses et puis si on
prend par exemple ne serait ce que le
panier de la ménagère j'ai pas rentrer
dans les chiffres mais si on prend tout
le panier de la ménagère c'est quand
même une économie globalement de 13
euros par ménage et par an en global et
pour les trains de personnes les plus
pauvres seulement de 10 euros par ménage
et par an ce qui est beaucoup moins
finalement que à la fois le chèque
inflation le chèque énergie ou le chèque
alimentation pour bien sûr ceux sur ce
point précis d'ailleurs du pouvoir
d'achat dans un instant mais juste avant
de parler un peu plus de du fond sur la
forme il a été aussi peut-être reprocher
encore une fois emmanuel macron d'avoir
été peut-être un peu plus autant d'avoir
été plus dix ans et la compassion c'est
plus ressenti du côté de marine le pen
aussi en fait chacun sait un peu adressé
assis à ses côtés il ya une fausse
compassion on l'a bien vu à sur
l'histoire de la tva franchement que la
tv a bénéficié à marine le pen comme a
pas besoin c'est pas de la compassion
vis-à-vis des gens qui n'ont pas de
pouvoir d'achat de l'autre côté un peu
on peut le voir d'autres de façon
différente c'est une attitude du
président la république d'abord y avait
des passages qui était moi j'étais j'ai
regardé attentivement c'était des
passages qui était très énervé je pense
qu'il a quand même gardé son calme acea
de manière assez royal ou présidentielle
je sais pas comment te dire ça parce que
parce qu'il y avait quand même des
énormités qui était sorti donc on peut
analyser ça comme étant certains vont
dire quelque chose dans l'attitude du
président qui peut paraître hautain et
d'autres comme quelque chose depuis de
pugnacité et de volonté de trouver que
c'est pas vrai voilà donc il ya deux
façons de voir les choses vous avez
parlé de du fonds pour y revenir sur les
propositions pouvoir d'achat c'était
l'un des premiers sujet qui a été abordé
alors du débat d'hier
proposition de baisse de tva proposition
du côté de votre candidat sur les fameux
chèque qui sont distribués chaque
alimentaire il ya eu aussi le le
bouclier sur le gaz l'électricité remise
à la pompe aussi de 18 centimes qui
serait pour l'instant maintenu quoi
qu'il en soit quand on écoute le débat
d'hier on a quand même le sentiment
qu'il ya encore de l'argent magique en
france non halal part et d'autre on peut
lui par les hors 600 milliards de dettes
on part sur un déficit de balance
commerciale de 85 milliards oui oui non
mais on peut considérer ça comme ça on
est dans une situation de crise
exceptionnelle a ressenti hier dans le
débat on avait l'impression que les
billets avait des solutions que ce soit
vous avez deux nous avait deux faces que
vous avez deux projets totalement
différent d'un côté et effectivement on
est des ans soutient le temps qu'il faut
le temps qu'il faut pour venir en aide
aux ménages les plus modestes c'est
toute la panoplie des chèques qu'on a
mis en place c'est aussi le bouclier
tarifaire sur l'énergie et messer sont
des mesures provisoires c'est pas la
même chose que de baisser la tva de
manière pérenne at vitam aeternam qu'il
a fait un trou au niveau du budget de
l'état qui est considérable je crois que
de mémoire pour pour pour le si on prend
que l'essence à la pompe c'est quelque
chose de l'ordre de 10 milliards si on
prend le panier de la ménagère c'est de
l'ordre de 3 milliards 8 et saas et
pérenne c'est quelque chose que vous
perdez tout le temps et régulièrement
alors que de l'autre côté effectivement
ce sont des mesures qui sont temporaires
qui restera le temps qu'il faut mais le
jour où la situation va mieux ça
s'arrête mais c'est pas la même chose
mais aujourd'hui on continue de creuser
on vous a mené mais c'est enfin quelque
part alors il ya un jeu mais ses parts à
la veille de ce second tour aussi
avoir un discours de vérité envers les
électeurs que de leur dire et on
pourrait parler aussi de la retraite et
l'âge de la retraite sur lesquels chacun
des deux candidats ont pas forcément été
le plus très clair et on a bien senti un
peu gêné aux entournures parce que quoi
qu'il en soit il faudra travailler plus
il faudra rembourser cette dette il
faudra en trouver de l'argent et de ce
côté-là non une le pen est pas très
clair dans ce projet parce qu'en réalité
si vous dites pour les moins de 20 ans
et 40 annuités et ils partent à 60 ans
pour tout le reste c'est plutôt 67 que
64 vous voyez déjà et puis il ya pas que
ça avant le projet de la réforme de
retraites du président de république
bien évidemment l'âge de la retraite
c'est un problème on l'a vu c'est ce qui
nous a aussi coûté pendant le mandat sur
la réforme des retraites moi j'aurais
adoré qu'on fasse la retraite universel
par points parce que pour moi c'est la
plus équitable et quand on a commencé à
parler effectivement du seuil de l'âge
de départ à la retraite l'aca a posé
problème est bon les français n'ont pas
voulu contacter néanmoins on le sait il
va falloir à un moment ou un autre on
travaille plus longtemps mais ça peut
pas être que dans un sens c'est pas
simplement le retarder l'âge de départ à
la retraite il ya plein de il ya plein
d'autres mesures le la retraite minimum
à 1100 euros ça c'est quelque chose
d'important pour les gens qui ont les
plus petites retraites sa marine le pen
ça n'existe pas chez ed je vous prendre
un autre exemple l'accompagnement des
seniors puisque c'est bien de tarder
parce qu'on en a besoin de rééquilibrer
les comptes pour maintenir cette
retraite par répartition qui est quelque
chose l'intergénérationnel que le monde
entier nous envie mais il faut aussi
s'occuper de la problématique des
seniors on va dire 50 55 ans jusqu'à 65
ans pour qu'il reste dans l'emploi et la
veille avoir des gens y avoir un effort
énorme fait sur sur la formation
professionnelle et sur le tutorat et sur
le moteur ans que par exemple les
allemands savent très bien faire je vous
qu'on s'en inspire en quelques mots
parce qu'il ya d'autres sujets que
j'aurais souhaité aborder aussi en 106 à
emmanuel macron est aussi réélue qu'il
ya une demande envers les entreprises
que les entreprises s'impliquent aussi
et je pense à ça notamment avec la prime
qui porte son nom la prime va comporter
jusqu'à 6000 euros ça ça veut dire aussi
que les entreprises doivent faire des
efforts doivent prendre leur part aussi
alors deux parce que c'est important
vous avez d'un côté l'augmentation du
salaire demandé aux entreprises de 10%
mais bon il ya des sas et la proposition
de marine le pen mais il ya des
entreprises qui pourront pas le faire
honnêtement elles peuvent le faire sur
un one shot mais peuvent pas le faire de
manière régulière et en corse et des
recettes qui rateront pas ce qu'on les
exonèrent de toute cotisation fiscale et
de l'autre côté c'est de dire que
j'ai perdu le fil c'est sur proposition
des manuels macron et qui était
d'augmenter cette prime qui était versée
c'est que la prime l'idée c'est quoi
c'est aujourd'hui vous avez un certain
nombre d'entreprises qui versent des
dividendes à leurs actionnaires demain
ces entreprises seront obligées
d'abonder pour les salariés de la même
manière en participation et
l'intéressement on verra et pour celles
qui ne peuvent pas le faire parce
qu'elle ne verse pas de dividende
d'accord on augmente la plume à condom
la passe à 6011 ça veut pas dire que
tout le monde touchera 6 milo mais dès
que vous avez des bénéfices ou en tout
cas des dividendes vous pouvez
redistribués à vos salariés le pouvoir
d'achat on a beaucoup parlé au cours de
cet échange c'est l'une des
préoccupations si ce n'est la première
des préoccupations des français si on
peut voir un petit tableau avec les
chiffres qui selon été compilés par
ipsos notamment et qui reviennent
surtout sa préoccupation principale y en
ad'autres si on en a peut-être un petit
peu moins parler on entend que toujours
on peut en parler c'est la question de
l'environnement même si là on a appris
mais que par emmanuel macron que son
prochain premier ministre s'il était
réélu très en charge de cette question
la plus spécifiquement il ya la question
de l'immigration de la sécurité et de
tout ça on va pas avoir le temps de dire
revenir mais ce n'était pas le but de
notre échange ce matin néanmoins il ya
un autre chiffre sur lequel je voudrais
vous faire réagir ça ça a été réalisée
avant le débat d'hier pour seulement 41
des % des français emmanuel macron veut
vraiment changer les choses c'est 63%
pour marine le pen
mais parce que peut-être nous on
s'inscrit dans une continuité de
l'action qu'on a commencé à mener on a
eu une première partie c'est pour ça
qu'un quinquennat c'est coup on a une
première partie en plus haut on a quand
même subi quelques crises mais la
première partie c'était vraiment de
relancer l'économie pourquoi relancer
l'économie libérer l'économie libérer
des entreprises de manière à ce qu'elles
puissent être performante compétitive et
qu'elle crée de l'emploi c'est ce qui
s'est fait baisse du chômage comme on
n'a jamais vu notamment pour les jeunes
ça s'était pas vu depuis 40 ans et la
deuxième partie du projet initial du
présent demain qu'on sait qu'une fois
qu'on a fait ça on attaque vraiment le
social pour par des réformes de fond que
ce soit sur l'hôpital avec la santé que
ce soir on l'a vu sur les retraites mais
que ce soit l'apprentissage on a
commencé c'est un vrai succès voilà il
ya 10 à toutes ces mesures là donc d'un
côté effectivement mis à sac une
continuité ou un vaccin et de l'autre
côté c'est un programme de rupture mais
c'est un problème de rupture qui ne
tient pas qui va appauvrir les gens plus
que les gens ne le croient et avec
finalement un projet qui est fait de ce
mouvement et qui sortent à la réalité de
la vie de tous les jours mais par
rapport à cette situation est ce que
vous n'avez pas peur non plus que ce
soit une fois de plus peut-être un vote
contre et par votre cour il faudra
composer ensuite avec et puis composé
aussi pour le troisième tour celui des
législatives c'est compliqué c'est là on
va pas on ne va pas avoir le ton mais
c'est là il va falloir un jour rebondir
sur la réforme de nos institutions parce
que vous voyez bien que
l'élection du président à deux tours
quelques
dans la constitution de 58 pose un
problème au premier tour forcément vous
choisissez ya pléthore de candidats on
en avait 12 donc forcément vous trouver
un candidat qui vous ressemble plus et
pour lequel vous allez voter et au
deuxième tour forcément il ya tout une
grande majorité de français qui se
retrouve même à qui se retrouvent plus
parce qu'ils ont deux candidats qu'ils
n'ont pas forcément choisi est là pour
le coup effectivement souvent et on l'a
vu avec sur la prédiction et vote pour
celui ou celle qu'ils considèrent comme
étant le moins pire pour nous plus
proche de notre guillemets nous ce
qu'ils pensent effectivement faudra
revenir sur ce système des institutions
et puis peut-être sur les abstentions
l'absentionnisme peut-être justement en
deux mots également vous êtes beaucoup
impliqué sur cette question là vous avez
lancé un groupe de réflexion aussi ce
sera notre notre mot de la fin
abstentionnistes vous leur dites quoi
dimanche pour qu'ils agissent simplement
aux absentionnistes le note démocratie
quand même bien fait enfin envie bien en
france et que l'abstention c'est la pire
des réponses puisque en fait vous faites
du ni-ni et vous donner des voix soit
l'un soit l'autre en n'allant pas voter
et après moi je préfère que les gens
aillent voter et puis on leur âme et
conscience à la limite aux têtes on
parler de la réforme des institutions de
penser à faire quelque chose sur l'autre
bord mais l'abstention c'est la pire des
choses qu'on vous abstenez finalement
vous pouvez difficilement reprocher quoi
que ce soit aux vainqueurs dans
l'application de son projet merci bruno
milian député modem des aides ils
viennent d'être venu sur ce plateau à
quelques jours du second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
[Musique]
en retour en direct sur tv 78 pour
continuer à parler de cette élection
présidentielle dimanche 24 avril nous
saurons qui d'emmanuel macron marine le
pen sera le président de la république
jusqu'en 2027 c'est l'occasion pour nous
de faire un point sur le rapport de
force dans les yvelines entre la
république en marche et le rassemblement
national bixente maya scientiste et
banda rejoint un plateau bonsoir bixente
bonsoir de la rédaction de tv 60,18
petit retour en arrière bixente quels
étaient les résultats du premier tour
sur sur l'ensemble du département et
bien tout d'abord arrivé en tête dans
les yvelines emmanuel macron a récolté
33 % des suffrages le président sortant
de france jean luc mélenchon qui lui se
situe à près de 23% en troisième
position la candidate du rassemblement
national marine le pen décroche elle
plus de 13% des voix mais si on rentre
dans le détail bixente ce qui a des
tendances qui se dégagent alors oui sur
les 259 commune yvelinoise le candidat
de la république en marche est en tête
quand même dans 200 une commune sans
surprise emmanuel macron domine dans la
plupart des grandes villes du
département des zones urbaines plutôt
aisée souvent proche de paris qui
représente une partie de la france on
peut le dire qu'il va bien puisque a
contrario dans les villes urbaines et
populaire c'est jean luc mélenchon qui
arrive en tête est liée aussi les
communes rurales là aussi ça change mais
effectivement dans certains villages
yvelinois notamment centre du
département autour de montfort l'amaury
et maule ou encore dans le rang boyita
et la vallée de chevreuse qu'en est il
justement des résultats de marine le pen
dans le département des yvelines la
candidate du rassemblement national
grégory est en tête dans quarante et une
communes ce sont des villages ruraux de
200 à 1000 habitants des municipalités
situées au nord du département
essentiellement autour de mantes la
jolie à la limite avec l'eure et loire à
l'ouest et leur et le val d'oise au nord
nous pouvons donc considérer qu'il
représente une france périurbaines
populaire est lui aussi quelques
résultats notables à relever oui marine
le pen réalise une performance
électorale notamment sur les territoires
ouvriers la rive en tête à flins sur
seine commune où est située l'usiné
historique de renault puis à gargenville
également il faut savoir qu'elle était
déjà arrivé en tête au premier tour en
2007 dans cette ville pas de grands
changements donc là dedans pour le
second tour de dimanche le mystère plane
autour du positionnement des électeurs
yvelinois de jean luc mélenchon
abstention vote blanc ou bascule vers
l'un des deux candidats réponse dimanche
soir
résultat donc dimanche soir à 20h merci
bixente je vous précise qu'on sera aussi
au lendemain de cette élection au
deuxième tour de cette élection
présidentielle tv 60,18 vous proposera
une édition spéciale pour revenir
justement sur le résultat de ce désir de
ce deuxième tour
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également ce chiffre
120 le nombre de conducteurs recherché
par le groupe sa vague pour compléter
ses effectifs la société a organisé
cette semaine une journée découverte
destinée aux demandeurs d'emploi
justement bixente mayence insisté ban a
suivi et la matinée j'en suis très
contente parce que je cherche du travail
depuis tellement longtemps ça paraît
correspondre à ce que je peux faire
monter à bord d'un de ses bus pour
découvrir le métier de conducteur c'est
ce qu'a proposé le groupe savak à une
dizaine de demandeurs d'emploi ce mardi
19 avril je suis ravi de pouvoir avoir
cette opportunité ouverte parce que
le métier que je faisais
il est mort en quelque sorte tout ce que
je sais faire n'est plus reconnue
je n'en dis moi ça me remet dans le bain
puis ça ça me permet de voir comment la
société comment les suisses défendre
fonctionne actuellement au programme de
la matinée une réunion de présentation
de la société et de ses métiers suivie
d'une découverte de lignes régulières
entre la verrière et saint rémy les
chevreuse on réalise dans le cas des
recrutements des stages de ce type là
plutôt sur des heures de pointe là
c'était vraiment pour avoir une première
approche pour que les gens puissent se
projeter sur que fait un conducteur de
car quand il est en phase de conduite
comment ça se passe avec ses clients
après avoir déjeuné ensemble après midi
est consacré à de nouvelles discussions
et des entretiens individuels l'occasion
d'aborder les métiers possibles entre
tourisme lignes régulières transport
d'entreprise scolaire mais aussi les
contraintes il faut bien sûr se lever
tôt le matin puisque nous emmenons soit
les personnels soient les enfants à
l'école ou au travail vous comprenez
bien qu'on démarre leur journée avant
eux et le soir on finit aussi après eux
puisqu'on y ramène de l'emploi vers leur
domicile le groupe savak recherche une
centaine de conducteurs pour
reconstituer les effectifs d'avant
qu'ovide et amorcer convenablement la
période de tourisme estival
tribu jaune ou rouge pour fêter sa
réouverture le parc france miniature et
l'encours a proposé dont propose
désormais un nouvel espace dédié à koh
lanta deylaud a été inauguré en présence
de clément ce castel célèbre
participante de l'émission télévisée
bixente mais rien senti steban et
patrick jacques de dixmude paul
reportages plus nécessaire d'envoyer sa
candidature pour se défier sous les
couleurs des tribus jaune ou rouge un
espace de jeu koh lanta inaugurée dans
le parc france miniature par l'une des
figures emblématiques de la célèbre
émission clémence castel dans cet
univers on retrouve l'univers koh lanta
évidemment et toutes les épreuves qui
vont avec il ya une épreuve de chasse au
trésor c'est un milieu très très
aquatique donc forcément dans koh lanta
on retrouve de l'eau que ce soit sur les
plages ou même
par la pluie malheureusement parfois
petits et grands pourront traverser les
bambous dans le but d'en sortir le moins
30 est possible jusqu'à l'affrontement
final sur la mythique épreuve des
poteaux pour tous les les fans de
l'émission mais voilà ils vont retrouver
tout tout ce qui entoure et tout ce qui
fait rêver dans koh lanta c'est à dire
laventure le dépassement de soi et je
suis sûr que les familles vont passer un
très bon moment dans cet univers un
espace pensé avec alp la société de
production de koh lanta n'a fallu à peu
près un nom en termes de conception
entre la réflexion et la l'inauguration
il avait déjà travaillé ensemble sur le
précédent lieu thématique du park
l'antre du père fouras du fort boyard
inauguré en 2007
notre constance c'est de garder des
marqueurs qui sont pour les familles ça
se voit à partager entre enfants
transgénérationnel ça c'est notre marque
heures et qui soit un côté ludique et
pédagogique mais en tout cas on veut
qu'ils aient des sensations des émotions
du partage il faudra donc compter sur ce
détour des paysans pour visiter le parc
aux 117 monument à petite échelle car sa
présence est irrévocable et puis un mot
de sport maiva hamadouche va bien
continuer sa carrière la rumeur d'une
retraite à 32 ans plané hier à princeton
et instagram ou la boxeuse de la team
farruggia elancourt laissait entendre
qu'elle raccrochait les gants joint par
tv 78 de son agent nathalie elf dément
l'information et parle plutôt d'un coup
de sang suite à une grosse déception
l'annulation de son prochain combat il
devait affronter la belge delphine père
soudan mais à dubaï mais son adversaire
a finalement refusé celle que l'on
surnomme el benna nos compte sept titres
de championne du monde 24 combats 22
victoires dont 18 par ko et seulement
deux défaites
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité très belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]